considering that the conference is
focused on carbon emissions haven't you
all thought of just like skyping in to
the conference in compromises are not
made in virtual spaces they need people
sitting looking each other in the eye
and making compromises and if there is a
binding agreement that comes out of this
I think many people are wondering how
will it be in force will the UN unleash
the monster that's living under the
Fukushima Daiichi power plant you see
very often the United Nations is sort of
a wishful image of trying to enforce
something but you know quite frankly the
United Nations is what its name is its
United Nations by free will and so I
think the issue of enforcement is
probably not at the forefront of the
agreement because we always have to
remember this is a journey that is only
20 years old in terms of this some would
say it's that's pretty old for what
we're up against basically we've left
ourselves very little time this is the
criticism right that we've got only a
couple years to make significant drastic
turns otherwise we're seeing four
degrees 6 degrees within 100 or so years
so I mean are we just kind of like you
know window dressing the Titanic here
what we are suggesting is affecting
virtually every citizen on the planet
where they work how they consume where
they will get their electricity from
what kind of transport they will use it
is incredibly complex what we're trying
to do against
that is very short if there isn't a
binding agreement how is the UN going to
offset the amount of hot air just coming
out of Delegates mouth
I think let me put it this way
whatever happens in Paris I think we are
beyond the point of no return in the
sense of a world having accepted its
going to move into a low-carbon future I
think we are no longer debating whether
we are moving towards a low-carbon
economy the question is will Paris make
it happen faster or slower